let me tell you the facts here this is
beyond disrespectful to the country to
the men and women the millions who have
fought bled died were injured defending
and fighting under that flag look NFL
players you want to protest go knock
yourselves out but when you disrespect
the flag you're doing nothing for the
people in this country to advance the
ball for the Forgotten men and women
that are suffering and frankly you're
spitting in the eye of every service
member who did serve fight bleed and die
under that flag and what's even more sad
Pittsburgh Steelers player the for me
former Army Ranger Alexandro Villanueva
he was even criticized by his own coach
after the game his own coach Mike Tomlin
said this take a look many of them felt
like something needed to be done I asked
those guys to discuss it and whatever
they discussed that you know we have a
hundred percent participation or we do
nothing they just discussed it for an
appropriately at the time they couldn't
come to an understanding so they chose
to remove themselves from it they were
not going to be disrespectful in the
anthem so they chose not to participate
but at the same time many of them we're
not going to accept the words of the
president so we decided to sit it out to
not take the field I was looking for a
hundred percent participation we're
gonna be respectful of our football team
as I said we'll have more on Alejandro
later in the program suffice to say his
jersey skyrocketed to number one on
nfl.com that speaks volumes now I'm not
sure why it's so hard for so many NFL
players to understand why Americans
don't want to see the flag and the
national anthem disrespected on Sunday
on game day and to me one of the best
moments you watch an NFL game is when
it's over
you have warriors the best of the best
athletes both sides they unite they get
in a circle they say a prayer of thanks
that I love if the NFL of players you
want to choose to make political
statements you have every right to do it
and I'm predicting right here now
tonight that the fans that disagree and
find it offensive they're gonna flee
that's also their right look I don't
support boycotts they never have but I'm
also not interested in watching this
behavior and the sign of diss
respect every Sunday as of today
Saturday is now my football day unless
this changes
not to mention this so-called show of
unity and then NFL is already showing
signs of cracking and is getting a
negative response take a look at some of
these headlines Hollywood Reporter Ben
Roethlisberger regrets Steelers
boycotting the anthem Trump supports fan
boos Deadline Hollywood Sunday Night
Football ratings down again on day of
player protests gray bein Roger Goodell
ignoring league's own rules and letting
players protest the anthem CBS Denver
von Miller ads being pulled after the
anthem protests he's a star player for
the Broncos
the New York Post to my limit Stadium
worker quits after the Bills protest the
anthem and just to put things in
perspective tonight for all of you out
there for all these NFL players that
want to take in the and disparage the
flag and the men and women who fought
and died for it let's do a little
comparison it costs on average ninety
two dollars 98 cents for a single ticket
to an NFL game and that's just the
average family of four this spending
hundreds and hundreds of dollars just to
attend never mind you want to buy a beer
hot dog a coke forget it
the average NFL salary 2.4 million
dollars some players making tens of
millions of dollars and even hundreds of
millions during the course of their
career so by the way they deserve it
that's fine they're great athletes now
meanwhile the average salary for a
private and the military is under forty
one thousand dollars a year now think
about this for a second NFL players they
have an opportunity to make millions of
dollars because of men and women who
make a modest salary that risked
everything their lives to give them the
freedom to play this great game and
here's another dose of reality
if average men and women protested and
pissed off their customers at work they
probably wouldn't have a job we are all
the customers by the way of little
leftist in Hollywood and all these pro
sports athletes so should the same
standard apply to them and as for the
president's comments under President
Obama get this millions and millions
more Americans went on food stamps and
by the way we didn't keep our doctors we
didn't keep our plans million Wars and
improv
and by the way he doubled the national
debt for our kids and grandkids and the
president right now he's trying to make
policies that are better for the people
in this country especially those left
behind so it seems to me you people
protesting you have no clue what the
president's plans are and as the
president said this is about respect the
one thing that should unify us respect
for the flag respect for our anthem
respect for the servicemen and women
that fought under that flag and for
those claiming this is all about freedom
of speech freedom of expression yeah I'm
total believer and I make my living
doing this but you know what these
players have every right to protest but
some of them are massive hypocrites when
it comes to freedom of speech on the
field you know there's a reason the NFL
some call it the no-fun League take a
look at these examples celebrations
banned including twerking and shooting a
bow and arrow in the end zone is that a
violation of free speech they're not
allowed to taunt another player or team
they're prohibited from using abusive
threatening or even insulting language
or gestures players are not allowed to
remove their helmet in the field the
player in the end zone and players have
been fined for wearing special cleats to
raise awareness for important issues
like mental health and domestic violence
and the lead by the way refused to let a
player wear pink to honor his mother who
is a breast cancer survivor after the
month of October and the NFL even turned
down the Dallas Cowboys request to wear
decals to honor the five police officers
who were killed during a shooting
rampage if you remember back in 2016
aren't these violations of freedom of
speech where's the outrage over all that
we're the protests and by the way we're
the so-called displays a unity not to be
cynical the NFL threatened to find Avery
Williamson of the Tennessee Titans he
wanted to wear a 911 oh one never forget
on his cleats for the 15th anniversary
of the worst terror attack on our
history I happen to be a big fan of our
g3 he got in trouble for wearing a no
Jesus no peace t-shirt ka no W and they
made him turn it inside out and RG three
also got fine ten grand for wearing a
Reebok t-shirt because
wasn't Nike and Nike sponsored by the
NFL or the sponsors the NFL and some NFL
players they get fine for wearing beep
headphones on the field the NFL only
cares about freedom of speech because
they're sponsored by Bose so nice try
Roger Goodell you're arbitrarily
enforcing the so-called rules rules as
it relates to free speech and of course
the media is going insane over president
Trump calling these NFL players out and
trying those in the left trying to make
this about race even though it clearly
is not let's take a look
race and you can't help but talk about
race with this if you have any question
in your mind as to whether or not he is
race baiting at a certain point of time
just think of Charlottesville it'll give
you some clarity the president comes out
and says it's not about race it's a
little bit like saying I'm not a crook
if you have to say it you're already in
trouble
sob referring to NFL players who
peacefully protest racial and justice
sob that language far stronger than what
the president said about white
supremacists in Charlottesville I don't
think it's a stretch to say that is a
bit of a dog whistle that is being
played out there a protesters were
almost entirely black and the team
owners whom the president was calling
upon to fire or suspend those players
are almost entirely white and the
president chose to launch this campaign
in front of an almost all-white crowd in
Alabama is President Trump a racist is
he making racist appeals to his
supporters see we're gonna be different
on this show than all of those shows now
the president came out and said
specifically these comments he made have
nothing to do with race watch the
president I watched a little bit I was
not watching the games today
I watched a little bit and I will say
that there was tremendous solidarity for
a flag and for Ark
that's nothing to do with race I've
never said anything about race this has
nothing to do with race or anything else
this is to do with respect for our
country and respect from you know the
only person is trying to make this about
race is the person who started these
protests remember Colin Kaepernick Hall
President Trump Hillary Clinton both of
them racist what's this you have Hillary
who's called black teens or black kids
super-predators you have Donald Trump
who's openly racist so what is this
country really standing for again that's
perfectly fine Kaepernick you want to
say that go right ahead but when
President Trump defends the military
defends the flag defends the anthem then
what they all fought for this it's a
massive issue and if the NFL wants a
league full of Colin Kaepernick's good
luck with that
because I predict Roger Goodell pay
close attention people will change the
dial they'll stop going to games as a
matter of fact they already are Saturday
is going to be my football day and
Sunday you'll watch ratings and revenue
decline precipitously